en la principal artería de lugares los
carteles ya la habana moscú aquí el
anuncio de un referendo para formar
parte de rusia es muy bien recibido por
estos habitantes pro rusos
todos estarán a favor de la anexión
votará en contra no veo quién puede
estar en contra y los que lo están son
bienvenidos a ucrania
en las calles de kiev la historia es
diferente con las de gerson y tuvo que
huir cuando llegaron los rusos la
celebración de un referéndum en su
región no debilita su determinación
nosotros no los invitamos aquí tienen
que irse nadie los quiere aquí cacof
casi toda la región de gerzón pertenecen
a ucrania crimea ucrania las regiones de
lugansk doñetsk pertenecen a ucrania en
la escena internacional el anuncio de
estos cuatro referendos de anexión fue
condenado unánimemente
washington denunció un falso referendo
que revelaba la debilidad de rusia el
presidente francés en la asamblea
general de la onu el cinismo ruso a ver
si no todos quieren nosotros ya debe
entender ahora que no puede imponer
ninguna voluntad por medios militares
ni siquiera añadiendo cínicamente falsas
referentes en territorios bombardeados y
ahora ocupadas
desde el comienzo de la guerra a rusia
no ha ocultado su intención de anexionar
más territorios justo antes del inicio
de la invasión vladimir putin había
reconocido la independencia de las
autoproclamadas repúblicas de donges
cannes
desde el comienzo de esta operación
militar especial pero también antes
dijimos a los habitantes de estos
territorios que debían decidir su futuro
la situación actual confirma que quieren
ser los dueños de sus destinos
la otan por su parte tiene una probable
escalada del conflicto moscú podría
aprovechar para invertir más hombres en
ucrania los diputados rusos votaron el
martes una serie de enmiendas que
preparan el camino para una movilización
general